hello hello hello so we're back again
back on the standout podcast back in the
sanctuary of Pete's place how we doing
PR we good we're good to go again well
and we are joined again by my partner
thank you thank you thank you very much
Accio cheers and we are joined by our
good friend once again head shoulder
knee the elbow and you know I always
watch if I was gonna buy listen we we
ain't here to be no agony Anse we're not
here to be a voice of a generation
we're not here to try to talk to you
like we're better than you or anything
we're just here having a laugh with no
research trying to get through the intro
in less than 20 seconds today we're
gonna make today we're gonna go against
our beliefs a tiny bit but is something
I guess everyone talks about it's gonna
be around forever is the world that we
live in now too soft it's a to pieces is
it to PC but we're gonna travel off of
it yeah of course I don't think it's to
pcs Wow can you be real pleased I think
we need to be more PC Aussie why is the
world to PC now you cannot voice your
opinion that doesn't last time you voice
your opinion everything you wasn't
allowed to do it is the last time yes
the biggest microphone in front of his
mouth right now yeah when it's awesome
you fought or something in your head and
you didn't say because you feel you know
what people are gonna probably today
morning on to her seat see that I was
going to say that [ __ ] that [ __ ]
world we afraid to say anything but no
one knows you your pictures not on
Twitter what are you scared to talk
about I'll tell you why the reason why I
know
now you put it out just say it we don't
care Selena [ __ ] just say it my point
is that I just believe if it doesn't fit
the narrative or the gender or the
popular agenda of the moment there you
know a lot to say yeah that's billion
and now you are one of those people that
has now compromised yourself by being a
[ __ ] oh I'm not saying what you want to
say cuz you're scared bored people gonna
say to you I'm around my room Pete thank
you now you compromised yourself as a
person positive like you know one thing
that always gets to me go on that
because I was listen to another podcast
today no say no names the podcast it was
about James Bond and they were like
James Bond or female and I once at a
llegar be freaking female he's James
Bond if you wanna have a female spy just
start your own female female called
James Bond now so you know the new James
Bond they just come out no there was a
trailer and then there's a there's a
black female spy and straight away as
soon as I was watching with some wonder
where they went they definitely passed
the men who want to her because this is
his last one you know like we know who
James Bond is mm-hmm let James Bond be
James Bond and the whole black male
thing I don't think you have to but is
your thought but would it be now he's
old now he's T's passed expired now and
even his hair don't even look good now
his heads good and he's not good
now be straight see I'm fine I'm saying
it with my chest I think you know
fireman
any ladies watching does it result will
it worse or better than none oh just
right out but I'm just saying there's
things that it's things like that I feel
like people are forcing a narrative yeah
on things like I feel like yeah you
don't need a woman called James Bond to
be a spy you can just make your own spy
yeah could there could be yeah in over
another film about another double-o
operative who is a woman I feel like the
footer with that Charlie's Angels film
because he tried to he tried to make
that Charlie's Angels film and then I
mean he made a new one and it flopped no
one's even knew it came out basically
[ __ ] yeah everyone saying he's just as
[ __ ] film but they tried to force like
the I don't even know us in the film
work on it but that many people haven't
seen it there's like that's not true
you just said brainstorm no that's not
true he's seen how he's running them
people right this is how this is how
people start voting for the Tories
because they think all the left-wing
people in the world hate the words like
brainstorm woozy a stick anymore because
you can say brainstorm as much you want
is ages yes some people take a few deaf
to give ages you can't say brainstorm
because of epilepsy did you see that I
could I'm saying a woman
is the world no thank you
go so [ __ ] off and Shawbury no one's
asked about it would not because this
false outrage that gets spread across
the internet this is how socially this
propaganda is about social media in this
room you exactly what you make a very
very offensive headline that will piss
off everyone is not OK
so then everyone assumes that this is
actually what people are thinking this
is why on GMTV every day you've got
someone who's like I [ __ ] I believe
in such a such a thing anyone who eats
me cause I sent to prison for 25 years
everyone saying this and she's just one
[ __ ] you sat there oh I [ __ ] hate
everyone who hates me I read something
about earlier they were saying the
gender dysphoria is like a genuine thing
where people have different-shaped
brains hmm so men and women have
different shaped brains but then people
who then certainly started suddenly but
people who have men bodies who identify
as women have similar shaped brains as
women so it's not actually it's not it's
not yeah it's not just something that's
robot no no no because of these beliefs
are we ignoring the truths of science
but that's once I believe us maybe but
it's still only two genders are they
competent like they today 57 now Simon
yeah now this cool alright I'm to get my
phone I'm under a man's body
Zorro's right yeah and a woman that's
born woman yeah doing the other day and
it asked me what do I identify as human
oh did you see that all cool where a
woman said the petrol pumps this is
obviously another clickbait this is not
a reliable yeah did you see that is
everywhere I can guess why so the fuel
pumps are sexist because they're too too
big for our hands someone tell her to
come off the earth so why are you
allowed this propaganda nobody it's the
people who hate it are the people that
it's the reason why they write the
articles because the only people who
talk about it mmm it's an outrage
culture why it has outrage culture
because of social media that so the
Daily Mail writes stories saying women
are complaining that petrol pumps are
sexist now so they make so they do make
feminism seem like an absolutely
ridiculous thing when it is actually
just women what in equal pay so they
just be that women are all complaining
about petrol pumps and no one is not one
person's tweeted about it and they'll
make an article by then everyone's like
[ __ ] off you stupid feminazi about these
women and it's just one person talking
about it
this is how the internet works you know
I hate now I hate like when something
comes on TV or something up his in sport
or when something happens and the
article they use Twitter as their
reference I like to it outraged at the
fact that this person slapped a lady's
bum on the first episode of this and
then you go on the arc when it's just
they've just gone and they've just
screenshot a bed with repeats of
[ __ ] just crying and I'm just
saying and this is a night and one
Twitter person bro and I'm just so what
is this is not real ridiculous no one's
even right in no mood it just like let
me just sit on Twitter wait for that
outrage to start boom
but it's good with deadlines so this is
regards to propaganda agendas
do you believe they're suffering kind of
like a essential organizations let's say
the loom noise that push these
intermediate outlets to kind of ness a
spread to people know what I think
literally what it is is because they
know it gets clicks so it's happened
once they've seen other news sites do it
hmm
and you can see how many there's a lot
of pages like right see the Daily Mail
they still still do so much but they
still use bit links so you can still see
exactly how many clicks each thing they
do guess so rival companies when I used
to work at different one just look at a
bit think you're plus on the end you see
exactly many clicks that gets ya see the
outrage ones so then you just start
nicking them from the Daily Mail so you
you it does come from the top down kind
of from the biggest publishers that you
see they've got the most clicks but it
is it is the public what the public will
click on is what people will talk about
because we live in a world where click
so it isn't like luminaries saying all
we wanna [ __ ] so some of the stuff to
say of a new world order is essential
currencies or depolarization right so
obviously a way to D populace is to
encourage things like I guess if they
trends or
stuff death car believe in
depolarization that's all gay people on
transgender people exist in countries
where you will get started effort thank
you now why is it is this the media
pushing it no it's not Brooke this is
just people that exist so will you get
killed for it yeah you there getting
killed for how they how they are they
that's how they are they are them did
you get me I'm not seeing that no no I
what depolarization does exist in a way
of like sterilizing people and some by
still existing vaccines believe
vaccination is still but I understand
why a lot of people don't because they
do sterilize Americans I don't believe I
don't believe muscles don't they still
native Canadians until like 2006 I think
it was something yeah we're going giving
birth and then it was like oh she's
bleeding we'll take her in another room
and then they make them sign something
and then they sterilized the woman
because they wanted to sterilize as many
and that's in one of the most
progressive countries anymore and that's
not like that's not some cover-up [ __ ]
just Google nothing bail ain't no better
knowledge coming out than a man with a
Stella cat in his hand just droppin gems
gems don't believe there's a lumen re
but I do believe there is a higher power
higher okay look what an America with
Jeffrey Epstein Grove he knew everything
about all of them he was in gone you
ever think that they were do you think
Clinton's and Trump ain't the same
people eventually but even in a higher
order or something coming from I don't
know be good to do not but that's the
name people have for it that's what I'm
trying to get is like we would have know
the name for there could be no no
no incentive belong you watch these
films where people do war like facing
people sell war and stuff too or they
need someone to win so if you look
deeply into it it's like I'm really
anti-semitic movement if you get deep
with it it's always the anti Rothschilds
and stuff and the rush hours like on the
banks and [ __ ] laughs and then
eventually it comes down to this finger
if you go far enough it's like they Jews
control Oh deep boy it is but the raw of
rich people in the world because the
Rothschild don't own that to some assert
they needed to own a couple more central
banks with that people chatting on
social media was that just me eating the
[ __ ] anything how do you feel go into
sleep every night knowing that you can't
be he can't he can't speak his truth
because when when when the gigs that
when the cameras off he can speak his
truth maybe when he's with his missus he
can speak his truth but right now he
doesn't want to speak his troops why
don't you want to speak your truth why
can't you general perfect go to bed at
night while and I can speak my truth to
the people who yeah we want to hear your
truth why why can't you - what did you
want to tweet today you couldn't what
was it like give us Elaine what was it
women was it racial there was no loan I
woke up today morning the Sun wasn't
shining stop I want to tell people to be
optimistic never like let down on your
goals always achieve and
Krishna strive for the best rise & grind
love your family love the people around
you talking about that obviously people
talk about come people talk about their
feelings or a tear - what's your
thoughts on that he's a monster of [ __ ]
question cuz I'm trying to do this in a
way where I know but I still see you
know like I see you know like they say
men can talk about their feelings and
men karbala on freaking we're thinking
well you know no I control my feelings
but they say a lot of men con I don't
necessarily think that is men I think
that is just possibly how you're raised
ya generation after generation how your
dad was t maybe I think a lot of men
don't know because if soft yeah they're
long hard yeah then I'm hardened yeah so
your your dad might with the new dance
that might be like by the surfing as a
man I believe you hold on to is just
it's like your man or would you have
told on to feel man like they could be
suffering your missus and you don't
obviously tell how you feel because it's
just a view of not appearing weak to her
because she needed to be strong lady
but tremendum if I felt like I needed to
actually just like guys let me keep it
ruin it like yeah you mrs. to understand
chalukya low you she wouldn't but
sometimes he's just
so you should still be able to tell them
and they configure [ __ ] but image
control there I call these situations on
the controller you might be I could be
some of the finances in the back of your
mind like [ __ ] all right cool I can't
cover up the rent whoever is this from
Anthony well you're not gonna let her
know to try to avoid the therapy have to
make know I think things like that money
you got and you're both like pay for the
rebel on your way making the rent this
month so you can swim that I can sort
out I won't bring I won't put that upon
her because I know she'll get stressed
about it so so even is slight financial
problem is this something I need to fix
in the gaff that I've not told her about
whatever you know what it is it's
something like that and it's just that
oh it's something where I don't even
know like a bill [ __ ] you man you've not
actually sorted out yet
and you're like yeah I don't worry about
that love and then you're like oh [ __ ]
that need I do but no but every night
before you go to sleep you think about
him maybe that's just me being
disorganized and not sorting ten things
I know but he's one of them things that
I tell my mates about that and I
wouldn't tell my girlfriend about you
know certain things make you anxious
that you can talk to mr. bun certain
things don't that's why I think a lot of
people get that Farrah beam [ __ ]
because
yeah yeah but you know what these
marseilles will be good if you have them
cuz not necessary you guys we know some
people obviously turn to drugs or
alcohol because they fuller they can't
express themselves properly expressing
some public out fear being judged
because you know me too much because I
make sense like not throat either one
refer people in the bus what happens you
tell your people like your this habit is
all finished laughing cool yes - bye
that was funny
that's why it would be good for them it
song you don't know boom all right it's
all this [ __ ] happened in my life help
me I need to talk to hands on a
therapist on the therapist so what about
you feel like some see all these are
celebs in that when they get hammered on
their in social media to night you feel
like they've so put themselves in that
Lane anyway so they just gotta take
their lawn to start a I agree or do you
feel like when they're depressed in
shame then I you know you love basically
bark or pressing me like and they come
out and they're like I've been depressed
yeah and obviously you read their shame
people are absolutely killing sympathy
for them but there's there's a reason
why because they chose that life for the
articulation so see we do know research
how many how many footballers oh yeah
very very low
like many working factories yeah people
who can't financially provide for the
family that's like that's if you can't
financially provide for people as a man
you feel less if you can't support your
family if you do this you can't do that
that's a bigger stress than people
calling you a [ __ ] because you boy why
do you also think that newspapers have
an obligation to not be like choose yeah
the exact
listen I'm just saying in it I knew that
girl's plan from cuz I just I just I've
never liked to look over anyway like
personally I'll just then there's me
just be the vision Megan by the way I
just surah Naas I you obviously didn't
make it as an actor she made it on suits
wherever she didn't get she was on some
Netflix from getting beat out before Hey
look at you now he's cool man what's
very cool ginger hurry
it was generic cool I saw some checking
out one day in a vision of the
highlighters guy no man anyway I did I
never liked to anyway and I just saw
that this girl has a little to him well
she looks like you know in films yeah
yeah there's this the pretty yeah
there's the pretty evil knew she looks
like a pretty evil new wife that's
trying to send the kid after bullying
[Laughter]
[Music]
the family or beer Odin
always gonna be led a no people's
families are like that when they've been
left in behind in the dust a lot of
people don't like her and I think that's
not because she's mixed-raced I think
it's because she's American because
Americans are know when you have like
that Americanism about that super no
reason don't get me wrong I did I did
feel like I saw certain things some
people say that too [ __ ] American hmm
and that you can know by just oranges
didn't like the look of her from
anywhere
I've been often the one from flashes
before who I think like the one from the
flash the TV set of flash basically I
look at them both on that how he could
have gone would you me not coffee like
that my entire life you can't just think
he could have got with someone bare the
same just done to you your marriage
you've defected from the family you're
gonna make money
whatever let's move you know what I
think I'm noticing it's becoming a lot a
lot of people are now just saying what
they want which is good I need to just
be bu mando
whether you're wherever and if you're
famous in that and people are gonna be
tweeting you whatever angle I just turn
off your [ __ ] notifications gonna be
enough people especially in his name
German the guy with the Joey just
looking he's just looking that dead yeah
they look much alike
did he say maybe his excuse for not
being a nonce was that he okay I
couldn't sweat until this year I had a
medical condition because I got shut up
defending our country
that's why Udi's
power on young kids get into power [ __ ]
[Music]
I'm not saying is not you know it might
not be true for if I send every copy of
the race isn't it the generation is like
him saying oh I hate the fact that you
think that police are racist no nonces
then the general you can choose what
narrative you like the amount of general
public people who are beautiful is a lot
lower than the amount of priests it's
like it's like it's like the train let's
just take in the whole is probably worse
in America is everywhere and then going
to people giving people where my go
lives her sister just had a baby and it
was about to get she was about to get
christened by this priest and they had
to switch priest last minute because he
got caught being a [ __ ] nonce that
they set him up and the police set him
up in there was that
some people young jewish kids babies
died from herpes all these people in
power it can for anything can create the
right love can create the right just
think all religion organized religion is
built to have power over people who know
you that's the reason why it was
invented like so long ago because no one
would listen to you unless you is like
under head that's why I'm video for the
head of the Church of England it's like
that's a [ __ ] one that's a fake cuz
they just took money of everyone and
that's why it's the richest [ __ ] it
was the rich that's why that's why I
switched oh no but I'm saying that
religion is just evil no organized
religion is and I think I think that
obviously you believe what you believe
you say your prayers wherever I feel
like I don't think you can look at
people below you you don't believe in
religion oh no no no just a singular
person I judge an organizer not if
there's anything wrong with that
No
you can be against religion or religion
but because he provides a safe
[Laughter]
comfortable speaking about religion all
right now oh yeah - Christian me because
if you go for the rigorous one right is
Eva wisdom can they say Quran hasn't
been modified or touched since it was
made basically right but it was made
years ago we go for like Jew if Jesus
was meant to or the Jew and then
Christian stem from Jesus right yeah see
Catholic I don't know where that just
popped up for him I don't know how also
is that why you oh yeah because every
time I'm like to my wit churches are too
good at pagan just now cuz I used to
roll to it but they believe in Jesus but
well listen I always got the computer
all day I'm gonna at the end of the day
listen just be a good person is who love
we'll love each other any kids and their
religion there's two sides of the road
there's right this wrong just stay on
the right side of the road people oh
[ __ ] that's a blood moral compass right
yeah but yeah anyway catch us on the
next episode of the standout podcast
thank you for listening in and yeah
listen to audio the shows on standout TV
with the dugout and elbow want to say
anything before we leave
not really well you'll be back again
don't be something to the culture before
we did read positivity and all that
stuff and just don't be so silly said
don't be so put her after a disclaimer
again with the older boys our feelings
our
yes don't be afraid to have your opinion
and we out